you're warm and comfortable in our
regular studio there
in central london talk to me about this
road map what road map
is the prime minister going to offer to
these mps
well if you look at the announcement
we're making today on the town's fund
180 million pounds
to towns like blackpool 39 million to
blackpool
uh for um an enterprise zone and the
illuminations being invested in
um warrington as well 21 million pounds
to warrington
out of the 101 uh towns that are have
been
earmarked for the 3.6 billion of funding
45 are in the northern powerhouse and
about 30 are in the midlands
engine we're refreshing the industrial
strategy
and the prime minister's focus is
absolutely on the leveling up
agenda in our hospital building program
14 hospitals
are in the northern powerhouse that is
what jake berry and simon clark and
others
want to see happen real investment in
infrastructure but also in jobs they're
very
passionate about creating the jobs in
the northern powerhouse
in their constituencies which is why you
look at the the skills announced
by the prime minister where anyone at
any age who wants to skill up reskill
upskill the government will stand behind
you and pay for that
skilling uh that you need to be able to
deal
with the post-pandemic world in the
northern powerhouse in other parts of
the country as well
i wonder why they're expressing their
concern then if all of this is coming
down the pike did they not know about it
no of course they know about it but i
think they rightly are champions for
their area
they want to make sure that their um
northern powerhouse strategy that jake
barry and others have worked so hard on
with myself i'm the local growth
minister as well as being the business
and industry
uh minister uh is delivered and that is
absolutely our focus
and you will see that coming through as
i said in our
refresh of the industrial strategy uh
the industrial strategy was a great
piece of work
delivered in 2017 in a world of near
full employment we're entering a very
different world today post pandemic
and that is the point they're trying to
make i think and they will see as i said
to you you know judges by what we do
look at the announcement today for
blackpool and warrington
and the other 45 towns that will get
that 3.6 billion
pound funding from the towns fund are in
the northern powerhouse
30 are in the midlands engine so you
know this is
real leveling up through through
infrastructure investment
as well as in skills and jobs uh in our
country
prime minister promised yesterday that
no child would go hungry
this winter does that mean that we're
looking at a u-turn over free school
meals in holidays
well what the prime minister quite
rightly promises is that
um during the summer we have delivered
to
50 000 uh vulnerable children through
our
um uh program uh that cost about nine
million pounds
of school activities and foods program
and we'll continue to do more of that my
own um
county of warwickshire uh he's using
that 63 million pound of funding that we
made available in uh
centrally to help children through this
half term and at christmas
as well in other areas as well i was
talking to carol shanahan
in stoke on trent last night where
they've provided 150
000 meals already and are doing even
more and we commend everybody
who's getting involved but the right way
to do this is through local government
as well as of course increasing the
amount of help through universal credit
and the welfare system for those most
needy families well as you know a lot of
that money's already gone from the local
councils and the
uh tax credit the universal credit the
20 pounds a week that you've put forward
that is being scrapped in april unless
you want to tell us something different
this morning
well i will not preempt any fiscal
announcements by the chancellor
but that additional 9 billion has been
welcomed by families and i'm glad to see
labour have given up i hope they've
given up you may want to ask them on
scrapping the universal credit
system because that is the best way to
help those most in need those families
that really need the additional
help at this time so just to clarify
that 20 pounds
a week that is in place at the moment
due to go in april could you could
review that could you as a government
well that as as you quite rightly
pointed out that will last until
uh next year but i i cannot as
you would completely understand okay
pre-amp the chancellor or any fiscal
announcements that he may wish
uh to make but of course we review all
of our interventions in the economy
we've put 200 billion pounds
behind making sure that businesses and
jobs are protected
you've seen the winter plan you've seen
the jobs plan
we want to make sure that that people
actually are able to cope
with dealing with the virus at this very
difficult time you've heard the
announcement today on warrington
these are these are difficult times okay
and we've got to make sure that we
target the money to those that are most
in need of it
yeah nothing more needy than a child
with an empty belly though is that the
education secretary
said that he wanted 150 million quid
and he was told by the treasury he
couldn't have it he wanted that money
to be extended so that children could
eat over the holidays
if they if they needed to um
he says he wanted the money the treasury
said that that's not the case that
there's a bit seems to be a bit of a
battle
going on why not just give them the
money and it it's a win-win for the
government then at the moment
you are looking uh like scrooge
well i don't think there is a battle i
think the education secretary is to be
commended
for the pilots that we ran on school act
on holiday activities and food programs
i was very involved in those i was the
children families minister who brought
them into place really important
activities for those most needy children
as well as
food and when you talk to the people
delivering them on the ground as i said
i spoke to carol shanahan last night
these are incredibly important pilots
and we will look at how we can learn
from those and how we can build on those
the best way to do it as the prime
minister quite rightly outlined is
through local government 17 local
authorities participated
in that uh pilot and of course through
the
actual welfare system the universal
credit system delivering that additional
help
uh for those families that most yeah
we've discussed so it's it's a team
effort
this isn't about you won't tell me
whether that's going to be extended
after
april so it's not a matter of pointing
fingers it's a matter of feeding
hungry kids over the back over the um
the holiday break you know my question
is the education secretary says he's
asked for 150 million quid
the uh chancellor said you're not having
it and in the middle we've got kids
who are hungry well look again i think
you you are
quoting the education secretary and
speculating on stuff that i don't
recognize
there is absolute lockstep between the
chancellor and the education secretary
and the prime minister and this
government
to make sure that we target funding to
those families that need it
nine billion pounds more funding for
those
families as well as 63 million to local
authorities my local authority has
chosen to use that money
for this half term and for the christmas
holiday
other local authorities are doing
similar things the best way to deal with
this
is through both local government and
through the welfare system and that's
the right thing to do
we've run a pilot costing nine million
pounds this summer feeding
50 000 children will take the learning
from that and it's not just about the
food
as i said i spoke to carol shanahan in
stoke contract she tells me that in
wards
where families want to keep their
children safe during those activities um
they
also appreciate the food but more
important than the food to them was the
activities
for their children to be i'm not sure
that's true
i'm not sure that's true she's had three
name checks now she's gonna be very
pleased this morning over her breakfast
should marcus rashford and other sports
uh
stars stay out of politics no they
shouldn't
and i'm going to give her a fourth name
carol shanahan who's the chairman of
port vale football club
um is a force of nature she's a
brilliant superstar in what she's done
for her community
as has marcus rashford marcus rashford
is doing an
incredible job uh highlighting
some of the issues around this they are
complex what i do
appreciate more than anything else that
marcus rashford has done is he said
let's you know take politics out of it
let's stop the finger pointing and
and attacking people um over this let's
work together so we deliver the best
outcomes
for the most needy families yeah and as
a result he's had to go around with a
begging bowl via twitter
and and other uh organizations have
stepped up to the plate
literally to feed kids over the
half-term break
because the government has fallen short
well as well as the government's
nine billion into you universal credit
as well as the government's 63 million
to local government
many local authorities like mine in
warwickshire doing the right thing this
half term and christmas as well so it's
a joint
effort across the board by by you know
breakfast clubs we've supported with 35
million pounds
as well as other charities and local
people doing their bit to help those
children as well
okay let's talk about test and trace
finally should we
um another bad day over the weekend for
test and trace but last time we spoke
it was in the studio you said the daily
target of 500
000 a day would be reached in four days
time where are we on that we will
reach the target of 500 000
test capacity by the end of this month
in four days time
by new labs coming online smoke and
mirrors isn't it
500 000 tests when are we going to see
500 000 tests
well we're seeing 500 000 test capacity
tests normally follow so we're running
at about 300
plus thousand tests at the moment
capacities at 370 000 so normally
these things actually follow through and
you're seeing us you know we've gone
from
and you've heard me say this before okay
2 000 test capacity in march
to now reaching 500 000 test capacity by
the end of this month that is to be
commended i think
okay final thought before i let you go
minister uh dido harding who is uh chief
of test and trace
is she doing a good job i think she's
doing a
very difficult job um really well
i tell you for why because i you know i
i sit on the
uh local action committee gold where we
go through
uh the data on test and trace
and how well uh the system is working it
can always get better as the prime
minister
said we now have a hundred local test
teams doing the
that sort of in-depth testing especially
around
local breakouts of the virus
as well as the national infrastructure
and i think you know this has been a
difficult time but we have
you know i think we can only improve
further as we work together and i think
dido has led the team
in an incredible way she's working seven
days a week 19 hour
days this is you know a a joint effort
by many many people to be commended who
work
uh uh with dido and are delivering the
test and trace system
uh which is delivered what 1.1 million
people have been identified
and something like 800 000 have been
you know isolating stopping them from
spreading the virus further
that is to be commended